Remember, that a contract is
an agreement between our data model and
our views describing how
information is stored.
It contains constant strings to
represent all the fields that our user
interface will display, and
in the case of Sunshine,
that our database will store.
We've just covered all
the columns that we'll need to
use in our 2SQLI databases that
will store weather and information.
Now let's learn how these column names
constraints are declared in our weather
contract.
Let's take a quick look at the weather
contract class file that we've
given you.
The contract class has two inner
classes, WeatherEntry and LocationEntry.
Each of these inner classes contains
constant strings that define tables.
Right now, we only have column
constants for WeatherEntry,
the table that contains
weather forecast information.
The first constant is the TABLE_NAME
which, for the WeatherEntry,
is simply the word "weather".
The constant values as defined in
the WeatherEntry class match the values
we're storing in the weather table.
For example,
we've got minimum temperature,
which is defined here
as COLUMN_MIN_TEMP.
Pressure column is defined
as COLUMN_PRESSURE.
But we're missing a column
to define the unique ID.
This is because we're implementing
the class, BaseColumns,
which contains a constant called _id.
By adding an _id column to our table as
a primary key, we can utilize various
Android helper classes that rely
on the _id column being created.
The LOC_KEY column is the foreign
key we talked about earlier,
that points to records
in the location table.
Since the column names don't
actually contain data types,
it's usual to annotate these types
in the variable names, and or
comments to make our
contract more explicit